Good morning everyone,
as all of a sudden I'm the director of
IBM Research Cambridge.
It's literally just a few blocks down
the road.
I've worked probably 20 years in IBM
research,
primarily out of our New York lab,
but I moved here,
uh,
just uh,
three months ago to really start up this
new ai lab,
a refocus and significantly grow the
Cambridge lab that we've,
we've already started.
I intentionally chose a somewhat
provocative title to my,
a talk today.
Um,
the reason I wanted to,
the beyond deep learning,
it's not necessarily to say that you
know,
all of these deep learning techniques
are going to be obsolete.
That's definitely not what I'm trying to
say,
but I am trying to say that,
you know,
although there's a lot of exciting
things that we can do with deep learning
today,
there's also a frontier,
a,
you know,
a space that we can't do very well.
And so I hope to today talk to you
about,
you know,
kind of what is an area of a boundary
that we were not able to break through
at this time that I think is critical
for machine intelligence,
for artificial general intelligence.
So I'm hoping that today,
uh,
I can set that up for you,
hopefully,
uh,
you know,
motivate a additional people to come in
and study this because I really believe
that it's a,
it's a critical area where we're
additional breakthroughs are needed.
I'd like to first introduce a IBM
research.
Uh,
I don't know,
uh,
how many of you actually know about IBM
research?
Some of you may have heard of us because
of the jeopardy challenge.
So in 2011 we created a computer that
was able to beat the chest,
the jeopardy champions at that game.
I'm very handily has,
as a matter of fact,
uh,
some people don't realize that our
research division is,
uh,
is quite significant.
So we have 3000 people worldwide,
a 12 labs that are doing this research.
Our researchers,
uh,
pursue the same types of accolades that,
you know,
the top university professors go after.
So a Nobel laureates touring awards,
National Academy of Sciences,
National Academy of Technologies.
So we pursue a very rigorous,
uh,
you know,
set of,
of research in the areas that we focus
on all.
And although I put the,
uh,
the jeopardy challenge up there,
you're only as good as your,
your most recent results.
Right.
So I also wanted to make sure that I
talked a little bit about things that
we've done more recently.
So,
uh,
in 2017,
as an example,
uh,
we created the first 50 cubit,
a quantum computer.
Uh,
most people are kind of,
uh,
you know,
I expect to actually see some people
announcing some other companies
announcing simulators for 50 on the
order of 50 cubits.
And the difference here is that we're
talking about an actual 50 cubits,
a quantum computer.
Uh,
so we,
we also have the simulators,
but we have the real quantum computers.
I think what's also unique about what
we're doing is that we're also making
our quantum computing capabilities
available through the cloud so that
people can kind of log in and they can
experiment and learn about what quantum
computing is.
So,
so very exciting program for us.
We also,
in 2017,
we were able to show a near linear scale
out in terms of,
you know,
cafe deep learning models on,
on our servers.
We were able to show algorithms that
were able to exploit the quantum
advantage.
Uh,
so the idea is that if you,
in order to actually get the speed ups,
uh,
on quantum computers,
you need to be able to map problems into
a form where you can get that
acceleration.
And when you get that acceleration,
then you're talking about exponential
acceleration over traditional computers
that people are using today.
Uh,
so this particular result was an
algorithm that's able to basically map
small molecules,
models of small molecules,
uh,
onto the actual quantum computing system
so that we could demonstrate the ability
to find the lowest energy state.
So,
and,
and get that exponential speed up from
that.
Um,
you know,
the thing is that in 2017 we were named
a number one,
a leading corporation for a scientific
scientific research at a corporate
institute.
So that's pretty exciting for us.
I also wanted to just tell you a little
bit about the Mit Watson Mit,
IBM Watson Ai Lab.
It's obviously a very exciting
announcement for us.
So in September of 2017,
we announced that we were building this,
a $240 million dollar,
a joint effort with mit to pursue
fundamental advances in ai.
Uh,
the core areas are listed here.
So when I say fundamental advances in
Ai,
it's really,
again,
recognizing what we can and can't do
with ai today and then trying to create
new algorithms to go beyond that.
So examples of problems,
I'm just very quickly that we're
interested in,
in terms of the,
the new Ai Lab,
uh,
one area is that,
you know,
learning causal structure from data is a
very challenging problem.
Uh,
we're looking at how we can use data
that was captured due to a crisper
mediations are crispr gene in
activations,
which basically has very large set of
interventional data where they're
observing the whole genome.
Um,
and we're going to try to learn a causal
structure,
uh,
you know,
from those,
those intervention.
So that's,
that's one example.
Another example in physics of Ai,
uh,
basically what we're talking about,
there's the ability to have ai help
quantum computing and quantum computers
and quantum computers accelerate ai
algorithms.
So we're looking at problems,
for example,
the machine learning algorithms that
will help us to manage the state of the
quantum computer.
Also,
uh,
looking at,
for example,
the ability to,
knowing what we know about quantum
computers,
knowing that,
you know,
we're going to be in the small numbers
of,
of hundreds of cubits for some time,
that the memory bandwidth between a
traditional computers and the quantum
computers going to be relative small,
which of the machine learning algorithms
will we be able to map onto those
systems in order to get that exponential
speed up.
So those are just some of the examples
of things that we're studying.
Um,
also we,
we feel that right now there are two
industries that are really ripe for ai
disruption.
One is healthcare life sciences.
The reason they are ripe for disruption
is because that community has invested a
lot to create what we refer to a
structured knowledge.
So you know,
gene ontology,
you know,
Snow Med,
clinical terms,
all of the structured knowledge that we
can combine with observational data and
create new algorithms and insecurity.
The reason why cyber security,
the reason why that one is ripe for
disruption is because if everybody is
advancing these ai algorithms and people
start to try to use those ai algorithms
to attack our systems,
it's very important that we also use ai
algorithms to try to figure out how
they're going to do that and how to
defend against that.
So there's some of the examples.
The last one shared prosperity is about
how do we get nondiscrimination on bias
morals into the algorithms,
not just training on,
for scale out and accuracy and these
sorts of things.
All right?
Uh,
we,
we already had our first announcement in
terms of the new mit IBM Watson Ai Lab.
So at nips we announced that we are
releasing a 1 million video data set.
Uh,
the idea for those of you are familiar
and you've probably learned a lot in
this class about how people used image
net to make new breakthroughs in terms
of deep learning.
Uh,
just that volume of labeled data meant
that people could go in and run
experiments and train networks that they
could never do before.
Uh,
so we've created,
uh,
this,
this million video data set,
a three second videos were chosen for a
specific reason.
I'm the lead for this project.
Oh,
deliver is a,
has great expertise,
not only in computer science but also in
cognitive science.
And so it's expected that,
you know,
three seconds is roughly the order of
times that it takes humans to recognize
a certain actions as well.
So we're,
we're kind of sticking with that time.
Computers aren't the machine learning
algorithms that you were learning about
today aren't able to do this.
Well,
primary learned about so far was how to
segment images.
How to find objects within images,
how to classify those,
those objects,
but not actions.
And the reason why we also think that
actions are important is because they
are composable,
right?
So we want to be able to learn not just
elemental actions from these videos,
but then to start to think about how you
recognize and detect compositions of
actions and procedures that people are
performing because then we can use that
to start to teach the computers to also
perform those procedures or to help
humans to be able to perform those
procedures better.
Okay.
Now what I want to do is maybe take a
break from kind of the setup and get
into the more technical part of the,
uh,
of the talk today.
So,
um,
as I was saying earlier,
you know,
what we've seen recently in deep
learning is,
is truly all inspiring.
I mean,
in terms of the number of breakthroughs
over over the last 10 years and
especially over the last five years,
it is very exciting breakthroughs in
terms of,
you know,
being able to,
for certain tasks,
uh,
you know,
beat human error rates in terms of
visual recognition.
And speech,
a speech recognition and so on.
Um,
but my position is that there are still
huge breakthroughs that are required to
try to get to machine intelligence.
So some examples of challenges that the
systems of today aren't able to do.
So one is that,
um,
many,
many of the scenarios in order to get
the performance that actually is usable
requires labeled data.
It requires training data where you've
actually labeled the objects and the
images and so on.
Um,
while the systems are getting better in
terms of doing unsupervised learning,
uh,
because of the vast amount of data
that's available on the web.
Uh,
the problem is that we at IBM care about
Ai for businesses,
right?
And if you think of ai for businesses,
there's just not that much deep domain
data that we're able to find,
right?
So if you think about the medical field,
very deep expressive relations that are
required to be understood.
And of course a lot of labeled data.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
if you think of,
you know,
uh,
an airline manufacturer and all of the
manuals they may have and they'd like to
try to be able to answer questions from
those and be able to reason and help
humans understand how to conduct
procedures within those.
There's not enough data out there on
those fields in terms of relationships
and entities and so on for us to train.
So it requires a lot of labeling.
Humans actually going through and
finding the important entities and
relationships and so on.
So an important area that we need to be
able to break through is,
first of all,
why?
Why,
why do these machines,
why do these networks require so much
data labeled data?
And can we,
can we address that?
Can we make the algorithms better?
The second thing is that you've probably
realized that you train up the
algorithms and then they're able to
perform some tasks.
The tasks are getting more and more
sophisticated,
self driving cars and so on,
but you're still not training this
network so that it can form many
different tasks.
And even more importantly,
what happens is that you learn a model,
and even though you may,
as part of the training,
you may have reinforcement learning
that's not lifelong learning,
that's not just turning the cars out on
the road and enabling them to continue
to learn and aggregate information and
bring that into a representation so that
they can adapt to,
you know,
non stationary environments,
environments that change over time.
Another thing is that,
you know,
when we train these networks,
you kind of get it down to a certain
error rate.
But how do you keep improving the
accuracy even though the error rate is
not that bad?
Now go to them stone,
don't do well at this today.
And then the last area is that it's
really important that we're creating
algorithms that are interacting with the
humans,
right?
That can,
uh,
explain,
how they may have come to a particular
decision or classification or whatever
the case may be.
So we need to try to think about how can
we build machines that can learn,
that can listen,
interact with the humans,
be able to explain their,
their decisions to humans.
And so a big part of this is what we
were,
what I refer to and what many in the
community refer to as,
you know,
learning plus reasoning,
meaning that we want to be able to
reason on representations that are
learned preferably on representations
that are learned in an unsupervised
manner.
All right?
The first step in doing that is to be
able to make language itself
computational,
right?
So we are able to think about words as,
as sort of symbols and what those words
mean and the properties of them.
And then reason about them.
If you think about all the algorithms
that you've been learning,
they expect the information to be coming
to them as,
as numerical information,
preferably as real valued information.
How do you go from text to real valued
information that can then be fed into
these algorithms over time and then
computed on.
So one of the first areas here is,
uh,
his word embeddings.
Uh,
the reason I italicized words is because
what you'll see is that we kind of
started out with word embeddings,
but now it's a,
you know,
phrase,
embeddings document and vetting.
So there's much more to this,
um,
but let's,
let's start first with what do we mean
with word embeddings?
Okay.
The point is to try to represent ordered
as a real valued vector,
a that basically what that words means
in terms of other words,
right?
So,
so the,
the dimensions of that factor of the
features or basically other words.
And the point is that you can assign
different weights on how well that word
relates to these other words.
Okay?
Now the difficult part there is how do
you learn that representation that's
going to give you that objective of
making that vector really represent that
word and be comparable to other words in
a way that the machine can,
can compute on them.
So the idea is the first work earlier
work in this was,
all right,
how do we do this?
Such that those embeddings,
those vectors give you an understanding
of similarity between this word and
other words within your dictionary first
model here was what they referred to as
a skip gram model.
Uh,
basically what you try to do,
as you say,
given a particular word,
how well can I predict the words around
at the words that are one hop away from
it to hop away from it,
three hops away from it.
What they're trying to do is to train a
set of vectors where you minimize,
uh,
the,
um,
the loss,
the prediction loss of being able to
predict the words around it based off of
that word.
It was a very big difference for the
community.
Previously.
It had been mostly counts.
People just kind of count the number of
occurrences and then they would use that
to try to almost make that the wait.
What this was doing was taking a deep
neural network.
Well,
it was actually kind of a shallow neural
network to try to optimize or maximize
this law of probability of being able to
predict the words around it from that
and what they got from that is what you
can kind of see here.
This ability to place words,
symbols into a vector space such that
words that are similar are closer
together.
Right?
So,
uh,
the point is you can see and also that
relationships between words,
you know,
move in similar directions,
right?
So what this figure is trying to show
you is that,
you know,
you can look at the countries that are
here on the,
on the left side,
and you can see that there are similar
to the ones that are,
all countries are proximal,
the cities are proximal.
Uh,
the,
you know,
the vector that is going from countries
to city are,
uh,
you know,
essentially going in the same direction.
I'm sure.
I'm not sure if you can actually see
that,
but the point is that this kind of a
vector space gives us the ability to
compute on those real valued vectors and
then learn more about this.
So our very first simple thing is to be
able to,
you know,
uh,
be able to find other similar things,
right?
You have,
you have something,
you assemble Italy for example.
Can you find other things that are
similar to or related to Italy?
You can find other countries,
you can find cities within Italy.
Um,
so that's,
that's Kinda the first step.
Uh,
the,
you know,
so the first,
the first,
uh,
work,
there was this kind of distributed
representation that we're talking about
here.
Um,
the second is basically showing the
difference in terms of being able to
second talk is a paper was about the
accuracy,
the significant jump and accuracy that
we got from being able to do that
prediction based representation as
opposed to the account base
representation.
I put,
I signaled,
you know,
ibm authors,
people who are at or where it off ibm in
orange.
And the last one is um,
the uh,
facebook has actually recently we
released this fast tax where you can
basically go in and very easily create
your own embeddings.
So first thing was,
you know,
how do,
how do they create it and they went
after a specific thing.
How do you optimize that similarity?
But what you'll see from the rest of the
talk is that there are many other ways
that you might want to try to figure out
how to place things together.
Other constraints that you might want to
place on the vector space and how things
are represented in that vector space.
So that you can accomplish tasks from it
prior to,
uh,
these types of representation,
the ideals for how people would actually
go after representing knowledge and
language.
We're knowledge basis,
a structured knowledge.
So our original ideas was,
alright,
listen,
I have to be able to have a entities
that are well defined.
I have to have well defined
relationships between those entities.
I have to have a rules that basically
will give me information about,
uh,
you know,
categories of relationships or
categories of entities and it's great
humans are able to do that.
They're able to lay out an entire space,
you know,
describe,
molecules and relationships between
molecules or jeans and relationships
between genes and the targets that they
might be able to affect.
Humans can do that.
Well,
a machines don't do it that way.
Um,
that was the problem.
So the second figure here was even
though you,
you know,
you kind of go out and you're able to
find a lot of things and wikipedia and
Wikidata,
you know,
freebase or some of the examples where
you can find structured information on
the web.
Even though you're able to find a lot of
information out here,
and although this is a 2013 statement,
which you can see is that,
uh,
in terms of the types of relationships
and completeness of that,
this is saying,
okay,
well for the people that are in
wikipedia or freebase actually we only
were missing about 80 percent of their,
uh,
their education,
where their education is from.
We're,
we're missing,
you know,
over 90 percent of their employment
history.
Right.
So,
uh,
even though it seems like it's a lot of
information,
a really sparse and very difficult for
humans to be able to use the algorithms
that we have today to automatically
populate knowledge bases that look like
the form that we understand and feel
that we can apply our,
our logic to.
So one of the first results in terms of
going from that symbolic knowledge into
sub symbolic knowledge.
So the vectors that I was talking about
earlier was,
could we redo our knowledge base is
based off of these sub symbolic,
these,
these vectors.
If we were able to do that,
then we actually would be able to learn
much more data.
It's possible we could learn these,
these representations and fill out some
of the information that we're missing
from our knowledge basis of this.
First part was saying,
okay,
look,
I can take some of the information I can
find and freebase and other sources.
What I'll do is I can use text
information to try to build out these
embeddings.
I can find relationships are,
I can find a entities that are in
similar spaces and realize there may be
a relationship between these and I can
start to populate more of the
relationships that I'm,
that I'm missing from my knowledge base.
We're able to use this,
this,
this principle of the,
uh,
the embeddings and the knowledge basis
to then start to grow the knowledge base
that we have.
Right?
So,
uh,
this is basic.
The first study here is showing how we
took information about genes and
diseases and drugs from ontologies that
were available,
uh,
represented that learn vectors across
that structured space so that we could
predict relationships that weren't in
the knowledge base.
That's important because if you think
about how people get that information
today,
they actually do wet lab experiments to
try to understand if there is a
relationship,
if something upregulate something else
because very expensive.
If we can use this knowledge to make
those predictions,
then we can give other scientists places
to look.
Looks like there might be an interaction
here.
Maybe you could try that,
right?
Uh,
the second set of results is a more
recent,
uh,
basically,
um,
you know,
it was a challenge issued by this mantic
web community.
How can we better improve this automated
knowledge based construction?
So the team used a combination of these
word embeddings,
uh,
to be able to search for and validate
information gained from a set of
structured and unstructured knowledge.
So this is actually won a first place in
the,
uh,
in the 2017 semantic web challenge.
Okay.
So now we're kind of getting an idea
about how we would take a language,
make it computational,
put it into a knowledge base so that we
can aggregate it over time.
But how are we going to get the neural
networks to use that?
That's the next question.
Okay.
An example task of why you would want
those neural networks to be able to use
that is question answering.
You want to build up a knowledge base,
everything you can possibly find a and
then you want to be able to ask it
questions and see if he can answer those
questions.
We say that this requires memories
because the point is that if you think
about some of the other tasks that you
may have seen,
you provide,
once you train the network,
you provide an input and then you get an
output,
right?
You don't necessarily use longterm
memories of,
uh,
relationships and entities and all of
these sorts of things.
Okay.
Um,
so this is a challenge.
There was issue to the community
essentially in terms of being able to
read some sentences and then being able
to give an a question,
get an answer to that.
And there are different stages of the
complexity of what is required in order
to answer the question.
Sometimes it's really just kind of
finding the sentence.
Sometimes it's being able to put
multiple sentences together.
Sometimes it's being able to a chain
across time and so there are many stages
of difficulties in order to do that.
Um,
but what I want to focus on is some of
the early work in terms of creating a
neural network that can then access
those knowledge bases and then be able
to produce an answer from that.
Right?
So the expectation is that you build up
those knowledge basis from as much
information you can find previously,
uh,
you train them such that they know how
to answer a question,
the types of questions that you'd like
them to answer.
Uh,
and then from that,
when you,
you handed a question is able to produce
an answer.
The reason this is different from what
people are doing today,
it's not just about saying today what
happens is,
you know,
when you program a computer,
then you tell it,
okay,
I want to be able to access this place
in memory.
You know,
I do a query on a database and I say,
okay,
I'd like for you to give me all the rows
where the first name is,
is excellent.
The last name is why they can come back
and that's all programmed.
These networks are instead learning how
to access memory by looking at other
patterns of access to memory,
not program train it,
train.
So the point here is the neural net is
the controller of how that memory is
accessed in order to produce an answer.
Okay.
Um,
so what happens is that they,
it is a supervised a result.
So they,
they do train jointly with,
okay,
what are the inputs,
what's the question that will be asked
of that,
what's the output that is desired from
that?
And then,
um,
by providing many,
many,
many examples of that,
then when you provided a new set of,
of,
of information,
then it's able to answer a question from
that by basically taking a vector
representation of the question queue,
uh,
being able to map that onto the memory.
So the embeddings that were produced
from all the sentences that were entered
and then moving back and forth across
that until it gets to a confidence that,
uh,
in,
in an answer and transferring that into,
into an output on the first version of
this,
uh,
the first version that's on the left
side wasn't able to handle many things
in terms of understanding,
you know,
kind of a temporal sequences,
for example,
they weren't able to do multi hop and
second version,
which is much more recent,
is,
you know,
kind of full end to end training of that
control of the,
uh,
of the network in order to try to start
to answer these questions a while.
It's incredibly exciting.
Uh,
you know,
there's still many of the questions that
I was showing earlier that it really
can't answer.
So this is definitively not a solved
problem,
but you know,
hopefully what you can see is that how
we're starting to go up against problems
that we don't know completely how to
solve.
But we're starting to solve them.
And instead of just creating neural
networks,
just an algorithm,
we are creating machines,
right?
Or creating machines that have
controllers and they have memory,
uh,
and they're able to perform tasks that
go well beyond just what you could do
with the pure neural network algorithm.
They,
they,
they leverage those neural network
algorithms throughout.
These are recurrent neural nets,
lsts and so on.
But the point is,
we're starting to try to put together a
machines from this,
uh,
if you,
if you'd like to learn more about this
topic,
um,
there's,
there's quite a bit of work in this.
So one is,
uh,
in addition to being able to answer
those questions,
if we could better isolate.
What's the question,
right?
This is something that humans have a
problem with him.
Somebody comes in,
they ask you a question and you kind of
say,
what,
wait,
what's really the question?
You're,
you're asking me here.
So we've done work in terms of being
able to have better computers,
better understand what's the question
really being asked.
Um,
we need systems that will help us to
train these models.
So a part of this work is to create a
simulator that can take texts that are
ambiguous and generate questions of
certain forms that we can then use that
to try to both train as well as test
some of these systems.
Um,
another really interesting thing is that
a common sense knowledge is basically,
you know,
they refer to it as what's in the white
space between what you read.
You read a text and a lot of times
there's a lot of common sense knowledge,
uh,
you know,
knowing that,
the desk is made of wood and wood is
hard and all of these sorts of things
help you to understand a question.
Can't find that it's not a wikipedia
muster.
That common sense information isn't not
in wikipedia.
It's not easy for us to learn from texts
because people don't stated this.
Third Work here is,
hey,
can we take some of that common sense
knowledge?
Can we learn in vector space ways to
represent information that's common
sense that,
that white space,
uh,
and attach it to other information that,
that we're able to,
to read from,
from the web and so on.
Um,
you know,
some of the recent work as well as can
we,
can we use neural nets to basically
learn what a program is doing,
represent that,
and then be able to execute that
program,
um,
programs,
you know,
this right now,
people want to try to program a program
that takes a very sophisticated human
skill to be able to probe,
probe a program and understand it.
And in fact,
humans don't do that very well.
But if we could train machines to do
that,
then obviously that's a very powerful
thing to do.
Um,
we're also a paper that was just
published a couple of,
a couple of months ago in December at
nips.
I thought it was extremely interesting.
Uh,
basically they're learning how to
constrain a vector representations such
that they can induce a new rules from
those and that they can basically create
proofs.
Right?
So when you,
the reasonable proof is important is
basically that's the beginnings of being
able to explain an answer.
Someone if you ask the question of the
question from some of the other ones
was,
you know,
it's the apples in the kitchen,
um,
why,
because you have approved,
if you have the steps that you went
through in terms of the knowledge base,
uh,
able to explain that out.
Then suddenly people can interact with
the,
uh,
the system and use the system not only
to answer questions but to improve and
lift what humans,
the human knowledge as well.
Learn,
learn from the computers right now,
the computers learn from us.
And just finally,
if you'd like to do more,
um,
you know,
the research division is working on next
generation algorithms.
Uh,
those come out through our watson
products.
We have a watson developer.
Cloud makes it very easy.
You know,
you can do things like you handed an
image and it will hand back information
about what's in that image.
You,
you hand at text,
it'll tell you information about the
sentiment of that,
you know,
label information within it and so on.
So we have what we believe are very easy
to use,
uh,
you know,
algorithms that take many of these
things that we're talking about earlier
and make them very easy for anyone to
use and incorporate in into their
programs.
So I think that's it for me.
Any questions.